foreign
if you speak too much you will learn too
little
the wound of a dagger heals but that of
a tongue never
to be an ant's head than a Lion's Tail
always tell the truth in the form of a
joke
there was wisdom in beards all goats
would be Prophets
he who looks for a friend without a
fault will never find one
who asks knows one shame he who doesn't
ask knows too
as meals require two stones so
friendship requires two heads
have three ears two on the head and one
in the heart
[Music]
the sins we often regret are the sins we
never commit
[Music]
all riches come from the Earth
the voice of the people is louder than
the boom of a cannon
[Music]
the end of strife is repentance
[Music]
water will find its way
it is better to carry stones with a wise
men than to accept the meal of a Madman
[Music]
advice is a gift that can be expensive
for the one who receives it
one idiot throws a stone in the well and
it takes a hundred wise men to get it
out
foreign
you can tell who the good semen are
during a storm
[Music]
when someone's wealth improves all of a
sudden their House's columns appear to
be crooked
scornful soon grow old
you never know a man until you have
eaten a barrel of salt with him
give a horse to the one who likes the
truth so that on it he can escape
make friends with a dog but keep a stick
in your hand
[Music]
the sun won't stay behind the cloud
the bee gets honey from the same flower
that the snake sucks her poison from
quick horses kick the hardest
[Music]
however much fruit a tree Bears it
humbles its head that much more
[Music]
to be willing is only half the job
no one will give a popper bread but
everyone will give him advice
if you cannot become rich be the
neighbor of a rich man
[Music]
you are as many persons as the languages
you know
[Music]
the world is apart man but a spoon in it
foreign
God turns away his face from a Shameless
man
[Music]
when you are going in consider first how
you were coming out
[Music]
if a rich man dies all the world is
moved if a poor man dies nobody knows it
[Music]
even if the Nightingale is in a gold
cage she still dreams of returning to
the forest
it is not possible to step twice into
the same river
spring will not come with one flower
[Music]
He Who falls into the water need have no
fear of rain
the friend who helps me and the enemy
who does me no harm make a pair of
earrings
[Music]
a pain in the foot is soon forgotten a
pain in the head is not
birds are caught with seed men with
money
you cannot hit the point of a needle
with a fist
[Music]
a drowning man will clutch its straws
one with is good two wits are better
[Music]
whatever you sow that will you reap
you cannot put a fire out with spit
[Music]
priest on the outside devil on the
inside
[Music]
ashamed of what she sees in the daytime
the sun sets with a blush
a Mew can swim seven different strokes
but the moment he sees the water he
forgets them all
[Music]
a devil with experience is better than
an angel without
[Music]
dogs that fight each other will join
forces against the wolf
[Music]
the rose of winter is fire
[Music]
you don't satisfy your hunger by
watching others work
the woman who loves her husband corrects
his faults the man who loves his wife
exaggerates them
[Music]
a man will never leave a woman who knows
how to joke
[Music]